[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour cet entretien
exclusif de France 24 et de RFI la
guerre est de retour en Europe les
russes depuis 2 jours sont sur le sol
ukrainien nous recevons le chef
d'état-major des armées françaises
Thierry Burckard général bonjour bonjour
merci de prendre le temps au milieu de
cette crise à devenir nous parler de
cette situation à mes côtés mon confrère
de RFI Franck Alexandre spécialiste des
questions défense
alors je disais ce soir on voit que les
Russes sont allés à
kievensive en fait est allé extrêmement
vite est-ce que ça vous a surpris vous
qui êtes un spécialiste alors vous avez
raison la guerre est de retour en Europe
pour la première fois depuis 1945 depuis
1945 pour la première fois un état
attaque un autre état et cherche à le
soumettre à sa volonté je pense que
c'est bien évidemment quelque chose
qu'on doit bien observer et pour moi ça
il y a deux réflexions qui me viennent
c'est tout d'abord ça montre bien que le
rapport de force la force est de nouveau
un mode de règlement des conflits c'est
la première chose la deuxième chose
qu'il ne faut pas oublier c'est qu'en
fait manifestement pour faire la paix il
faut être deux pour faire la guerre un
seul suffit on doit pas l'oublier
alors on avait rappelé aussi que en fait
on a eu une grande période de paix et
que on avait oublié la guerre alors
est-ce que vous avez la pression vous
que cette situation qu'on voit
aujourd'hui elle risque de déborder et
puis en France est-ce que quelque part
les soldats sont prêts est-ce que on est
réactif à ce genre de situation la
guerre effectivement quelque chose qui
ne concerne pas seulement l'armée ou les
armées c'est quelque chose qui concerne
la nation entière et en particulier
l'importance de l'esprit de défense donc
on voit bien que c'est quelque chose où
tout le monde doit se préparer ça c'est
la première chose la deuxième chose
le rôle des armées pour moi il y a deux
volets il y a un volet qui est protégé
les Français contre la dangerosité du
quotidien plus probablement d'ailleurs
contribuer à protéger les Français
contre la dangerosité du quotidien La
danger du quotidien c'est les attaques
terroristes c'est la crise sanitaire
c'est les catastrophes climatiques ou
écologiques le deuxième volet qui est
bien plus dimensionnant mais néanmoins
qui est l'autre volet c'est bien
évidemment protéger les Français contre
la dangerosité du monde et en fait
là-dedans on y trouve la guerre qui est
un peu l'affrontement ultime ce qu'on
comprend également c'est que
il faut qu'on mettre en place une
nouvelle grille de lecture stratégique
en tout cas pour bien analyser la
conflictualité aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il
se passe dans le monde et au-delà de tes
crises guerre sur lequel on a vécu
depuis la fin de la guerre froide je
pense n'est plus totalement adapté et
aujourd'hui la grille de lecture
stratégique qu'on essaie de mettre en
place pour analyser pas pour imposer aux
autres et plutôt quelque chose qui
tourne autour de compétition
contestation et affrontement et qu'en
fait la compétition est quelque chose
qui est permanent et que pour les armées
aujourd'hui pour l'armée française
l'objectif est bien de gagner la guerre
avant la guerre c'est-à-dire de réussir
à imposer sa volonté à l'adversaire dès
la phase de compétition ceci pour éviter
d'aller à l'affrontement mais que pour
réussir à gagner la guerre avant la
guerre il faut être crédible et donc
disposer d'une armée qui est prête aller
à l'affrontement justement mon général
on voit bien que la guerre de haute
intensité est possible en Europe est-ce
qu'on est prêt ce qu'on a assez de
munition je pense ça serait sans rapport
parlementaire qui indique dans un
conflit de haute intensité de notre
aviation de chasse resterait cloué au
sol au bout de quelques jours seulement
faute de missile je pense que il faut
bien comprendre que la France elle fait
partie de l'OTAN elle fait partie de
l'OTAN elle fait partie de l'Union
européenne le temps est une organisation
de défense collective qui est fondée sur
la solidarité stratégique entre
l'ensemble de ses membres c'est quelque
chose qui est très important
l'idée n'est pas de faire la guerre tout
seul c'est bien évidemment de faire la
guerre ensemble et d'être capable de se
de se protéger entre nous dans ce cadre
là la et contribue pleinement à la
solidité de l'alliance est un allié qui
est fiable qui est crédible et qui est
solide donc ça c'est quelque chose qui
est très important à comprendre le temps
justement on annonce que un contingent
français pour arriver plus vite que
prévu en Roumanie sur le flanc Est de
l'Union européenne il s'agit d'envoyer
un message clair à Moscou également dans
cette partie de l'Union européenne en
fait dans ce que vous décrivez c'est
exactement c'est bien évidemment face à
l'EST mais c'est surtout l'expression de
la solidarité stratégique entre les
membres de l'OTAN et vous expliquez le
cas de la Roumanie effectivement qui est
un peu à proximité immédiate de la
situation de guerre que connaît
l'Ukraine et donc le temps a décidé de
renforcer sa présence d'envoyer un signe
très clair de solidarité stratégique de
positionner des forces en Roumanie et la
France qui est actuellement contributeur
majeur de la force de réaction rapide de
l'OTAN effectivement c'est porté
volontaire dit je suis capable de faire
d'assurer le rôle de nation 4
c'est-à-dire de de pays leader pour
déployer un bataillon en Roumanie
prochainement on va déployer environ 500
hommes avec des véhicules blindés des
engins de combat pour apporter un
soutien à la Roumanie mais aussi
apporter le message d'une solidarité
stratégique de l'ensemble des membres de
l'OTAN il n'y a pas que dans sur le
flanc sud il y a également la réalité de
ce qui se passe sur le flanc est en
particulier dans les pays baltes depuis
2017 la France est présente en Estonie
où on a déjà l'opération lynx une force
de présence avancée au profit de l'OTAN
dans le cadre de l'OTAN mais là aussi en
expression d'une solidarité stratégique
extrêmement forte avec l'Estonie
l'Estonie qui a nos partenaires majeurs
un des premiers pays qui s'est engagé
avec nous en BSS à nos côtés d'abord
d'embarkan aujourd'hui dans ta kuba et
donc au titre de la situation connaît
aujourd'hui le temps et la situation
crise et de situation de guerre en
Ukraine il a été décidé de maintenir nos
dispositifs on devait normalement être
élevé au bout de au mois de mars on va
maintenir un dispositif on va maintenir
une compagnie environ 200 à 250
militaires avec des blindés ça sera une
compagnie de chasseurs alpin donc
habitué équipé pour combattre à guéri
pour combattre en milieu de grand froid
on va également déployer en avance de
phase 4 chasseurs des mirages 2000 qui
vont se superposer avec le dispositif de
patrouille aérienne qui est qui est
disposé là aussi pour envoyer un signal
très très clair de solidarité
stratégique vis-à-vis de l'Estonie mais
aussi assez vrai signal de fermeté et
sans ambiguïté vis-à-vis de la Russie on
a aussi général pour la première fois
Vladimir Poutine qui a menacé en fait
l'arme nucléaire il a parlé
effectivement de cette question là
est-ce que aujourd'hui la posture
française elle doit s'appuyer par
rapport à ses déclarations
je reviens à ce que j'ai dit c'est la
solidarité stratégique l'organisation de
défense collective est quelque chose qui
permet de prendre en compte l'ensemble
de ces de ces menaces et de disposer et
d'afficher un message extrêmement clair
vous avez entendu que moi le ministre
des Affaires étrangères monsieur LeDrian
qui a expliqué que l'alliance était une
alliance nucléaire le temps est une
alliance nucléaire la France dispose de
l'arme nucléaire tout ceci fait partie
du dialogue stratégique et la France est
prête à assumer ses responsabilités
ces dernières semaines par exemple on a
vu le renseignement américain rendre
public des informations nous expliquant
ce qui allait se dérouler en Ukraine
c'est un exemple assure c'est un exemple
à suivre en tout cas il faut bien
analyser en fait la mise en place du
dispositif russe autour de l'Ukraine a
été quelque chose qui a été visible
massif progressif la stratégie
américaine et la stratégie des pays
occidentaux a été de dénoncer cette
présence qui était en train de monter de
dénoncer pour
dissuader la Russie c'est quelque chose
qui manifestement n'a pas suffi mais
c'était aussi quelque chose qui visait à
informer et à bien faire prendre en
compte la réalité de cette menace là et
je pense que si aujourd'hui la
condamnation est aussi unanime dans le
monde entier contre l'agression russe en
Ukraine c'est aussi le résultat de cette
dénonciation publique qui a été fait
donc c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement important d'agir dans le
champ des perception pour dissuader au
moins pour ensuite condamner l'agression
qui a été réalisée
on va passer un autre théâtre
d'opération c'est le Sahel général les
Russes sont présents on a les
instructeurs on a des mercenaires qui
sont sur place on demande aujourd'hui à
la France de quitter le Mali 6 mois nous
demandons les Maliens eux veulent que
moins de délai est-ce que vous craignez
qu'il est tentatives de déstabilisation
qui soit mis en place aussi bien du côté
russe que du côté malien si moi c'est
les délais que j'estime nécessaire pour
pouvoir quitter le Mali et nous
réarticuler en bonne ordre et en
sécurité donc c'est comme ça qu'on va le
faire on va conduire notre manœuvre en
bonne ordre et en sécurité
c'est très articulation en fait bien
évidemment la première c'est une d'un
point de vue logistique qui est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement lourd et
extrêmement complexe vous connaissez ce
théâtre avec des élongations énormes un
terrain qui est extrêmement abrasif des
voies de communication qui sont très
aléatoires donc en soit ça constitue
déjà un défi logistique et aussi un
véritable défi sécuritaire puisqu'en
fait bien évidemment les les groupes en
météorite sont encore présents il va
falloir donc se désengager en sécurité
donc il y a également oui possiblement
des manœuvres de déstabilisation qui
peuvent être conduites vous l'avez dit
on a actuellement le groupe Wagner un
groupe de mercenaires qui est déployé en
accord avec les autorités maliennes et
qui bien évidemment cherchent va
chercher à nous compliquer la tâche donc
c'est ça qu'on va devoir prendre en
compte je pense que néanmoins c'est
quelque chose qui est à notre portée il
faudra être extrêmement vigilant mais la
réarticulation va se conduire dans ces
délais là en or et en sécurité quel
bilan faites-vous aujourd'hui de
l'opération barkhane
tout d'abord l'opération barkhane il
faut pas oublier que c'est l'engagement
des armées et quand il y a engagement
des armées en opération on peut avoir
des pertes et payer le prix du son c'est
ce qui s'est fait aujourd'hui on a 59
militaires français qui sont morts en
opération dans l'exécution de leur
mission c'est bien évidemment je pense
d'abord à eux je pense à leur frère
d'arme je pense à leur famille je pense
également au blessé qu'on a eu ceci pour
conduire une opération de lutte contre
le terrorisme qui était lancé à la
demande de l'État malien c'est
l'opération Serval qui s'engage en 2013
et qui évite clairement la chute du
gouvernement malien qui sauve Bamako
ensuite c'est l'opération barkhane qui
vise à poursuivre la lutte
contre le terrorisme non seulement au
Mali mais également au Niger au Burkina
Faso au Tchad et en coordination avec la
mort Italie c'est ça le résultat de
l'opération barkhane et c'est finalement
des groupes armés terroristes qui qui
ont été contrées qui n'ont pas réussi à
développer un leur efficacité
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre en terme
de bilan aujourd'hui je pense que la
réalité c'est que finalement les
autorités politiques maliennes n'ont pas
été capable de saisir l'opportunité
politique qui était ouverte offerte par
la présence de barkhane et par le climat
sécuritaire qu'elle s'est évertué à
faire penser rien n'a été fait rien n'a
été fait pas de retour de la gouvernance
au nord pas de mouvement de geste
d'apaisement du Nord vers le Sud pas de
développement pas de retour de l'État
c'est ça en fait la difficulté qu'à
rencontrer l'opération barkham
ignorer le sentiment anti français qui
prospère est-ce que finalement la
communication n'a pas été votre talon
d'Achille c'est vrai qu'on a un vrai
sujet dans la guerre des perceptions
au-delà de la guerre des perceptions sur
laquelle je reviendrai je pense que ce
dont il faut bien être conscient c'est
que la guerre contre le terroriste ne
peut être gagné que par les armées
africaines c'est quelque chose qui est
assez capable qui est assez simple à
comprendre comment voulez-vous qu'un
paysan dans un visage
pense que finalement un soldat français
ou un soldat suédois de la force takuba
restera plus longtemps que le terroriste
qui est dans la région
celui qui dont il peut penser qu'il
restera plus longtemps que l'été en
risque au moins aussi longtemps c'est
son armée c'est l'armée de son pays et
donc ça montre bien pourquoi les armées
africaines c'est elle qui doivent mener
le combat contre le terroriste pour la
communication c'est la même manière
c'est de la même sorte de réflexion pour
l'armée française il est important de
conserver le soutien de la population
française et on communique globalement
la population française soutient
l'opération barkhane même si au fil des
ans forcément c'est quelque chose qui
peut s'errer en revanche la
communication pour convaincre les
Maliens pour convaincre les Nigériens
pour convaincre les Burkinabè que les
soldats français sont là et sont
acceptés par le pays elle doit être
conduite par les armées locales et par
les gouvernements locaux et s'ils
veulent que l'armée française soit là
pour les appuyer pour les aider à
prendre leur a tenu c'est eux qui
doivent savoir convaincre leur
population et d'ailleurs c'est eux qui
le peuvent c'est pas la communication
française qui est capable d'expliquer
pourquoi au malien pourquoi on est au
Mali pourquoi on est au Mali à la
demande de leur gouvernement ils doivent
également prendre le responsabilité dans
ce domaine là
la lutte contre le terrorisme elle va se
poursuivre a dit le président de la
République évidemment elle se poursuit
au sale même si c'est loin même si on a
lucrède à côté quel dispositif vous
allez mettre en place comment est-ce que
vous allez faire je pense que c'est là
le défi aujourd'hui auquel on est
confronté bien évidemment il s'agit de
ré-articuler la force de conduire et de
poursuivre la lutte contre le terrorisme
non plus à partir du territoire malien
mais essentiellement à partir de deux
pays pivots que sont le Niger et que sur
le Burkina Faso il faut aussi qu'on
développe considérablement notre appui
est très rapidement au profit des pays
du Golf de Guinée qui commence déjà à
être soumis à la pression des groupes
armées terroristes qui descendent vers
le sud néanmoins il faut qu'on soit
capable de revoir de rénover d'imaginer
une nouvelle manière de travailler avec
les pays africains c'est quelque chose
qui est fondamental et pour ça il nous
faut un peu de temps et donc c'est un
peu trop tôt pour que je vous donne le
plan exact avec lequel on va se déployer
sur articuler si j'avais déjà le plan
objectivement c'est que travailler ni
avec les partenaires européens ni avec
les partenaires africains or notre
objectif aujourd'hui c'est de quoi
réfléchir et de
co-construire notre dispositifs de
demain donc le temps qu'on va mettre à
se désengager c'est des travaux qui vont
être conduits et qui ont déjà été lancé
avec nos partenaires européens avec nos
partenaires africains pour avoir pour
inventer je pense qu'il y a un vrai
sujet un vrai défi d'inventer une
nouvelle manière d'être présent aux
côtés avec les pays africains pour
combattre le terrorisme c'est donc la
fin des grandes des grandes OPEX de
grandes opérations extérieures en
Afrique alors on décide pas toujours de
la durée des OPEX mais vous avez raison
dans le monde aujourd'hui avec les
nouveaux types de conflictualité où il
est nécessaire de prendre les choses de
manière beaucoup plus stratégique je
pense que les opérations qui durent
longtemps sont quelque chose qui en
particulier dans le champ des
perceptions sont difficiles à maintenir
un bon niveau c'est aussi probablement
la nécessité de mieux travailler de
mieux identifier ce besoin les pays
africains pour que le plus vite possible
il soit capable de manière autonome en
toute indépendance avec notre appui de
conduire la lutte donc il faut qu'on
soit beaucoup plus vigilant sur la durée
de nos engagements avec des opérations
qui doivent être plus séquencés plus
rapides et s'enchaîner mieux la
formation le mentoring est plus
nécessairement des soldats français en
première ligne
les soldats français doivent continuer à
accompagner les pays africains mais
comme je vous l'ai dit en particulier
dans la guerre contre le terroriste ce
combat là doit être conduit et il le
doit car c'est les armées africaines qui
peuvent gagner contre le terrorisme
général Thierry Burckard chef
d'état-major des armées françaises merci
merci à vous et merci c'est la fin donc
de cet entretien exclusif France 24 RFI
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi nos
programmes continuent sur nos deux
antennes
[Musique]